PROFESSOR: Here is
the answer, answer.
It's easier apparently to
write 1 over T. And 1 over T
is equal to 1 plus 1 over 4 V0
squared over E times E plus V0
times sine squared of 2k2a.
So the one thing to
notice in this formula,
it's a little complicated,
is that the second term
is positive.
Because V0 squared is positive,
the energy is positive,
and sine squared is positive.
So if this is positive,
the right-hand side
is greater than 1.
And therefore, the
T is less than 1.
So this implies T less
than or equal to 1.
And there seems to
be a possibility
of T being equal to 1
exactly if the sine squared
of this quantity, or the sine
of this quantity, vanishes.
So there is a possibility of
very interesting saturation,
in which the transmission
is really equal to 1.
So we'll see it.
The other thing you can notice
is that, as E goes to 0,
this is infinite.
And therefore, T is going to 0.
No transmission as
the energy goes to 0.
As the energy goes to infinity,
well, this term goes to 0.
And you get transmission,
T equals to one.
So these are interesting limits.
Now, to appreciate
this better, we
can write it with
unit-free language.
So for that, I'll
do the following.
It's a little rewriting,
but it helps a bit.
So think of 2k2
times a, this factor,
as the argument of
the sine function.
Well, it's 2.
k2 was defined up there, so it's
2m a squared E plus V0 over h
squared.
And I put the a inside
the square root.
So what do we have here?
2 times the square
root of 2m a squared.
Let's factor a V0, so that
you have 1 plus E over V0.
And you have h squared here.
So this is OK.
There's clearly two
things you can do.
First, define a
unit-free energy.
So the energy is now
described by this little E.
Without units, that compares
the energy of your energy
eigenstate to the
depth of the potential.
So it should be over V0.
So this is nice.
You don't have to talk
about EVs or some quantity.
Just a pure number.
And here, there is another
number that is famous.
This is the number Z0
squared of a potential well.
This is the unit-free
number that tells you
how deep or profound
is your potential,
and controls the
number of zeros.
So at this moment,
this is simply 2 Z0,
because the square root is there
and takes the Z0 squared out
as Z0.
Square root of 1 plus
e, which is nice.
So here, you can divide
by V0 squared, numerator
and denominator.
So you have an E over V0,
and a 1 plus an E over V0.
So the end result is that 1
over T is now 1 plus 1 over 4e 1
plus e sine squared of 2
Z0 square root of 1 plus e.
So it's ready for
numerical calculation,
for plotting, and doing all
kinds of things with it.
But what we want to
understand is this phenomenon
that you would expect, in
general, some reflection
and some transmission.
But there is a possibility
when T is equal
to 1, and in particular, when
this sine squared function
is equal to 0, and that
will make T equal to 1,
then you have a
perfect transmission.
So let's see why
it is happening,
or under what
circumstances it happens.
So for what the
energies will we have?
For what energies?
Energies is T equal to 1.
It's perfect transmission.
No reflection whatsoever.
So we need, then, that the
argument of this sine function
be equal to multiples of pi,
2 Z0 square root of 1 plus e
is equal to a multiple of pi.
Now, we would say what
the multiple of pi?
Well, it could be 0, 1, 2, 3.
Not obvious, because the only
thing you have here to adjust
is the energy.
The energy is positive.
And that's that
little e in here.
So this number n must
exceed some number,
because this left-hand side
never becomes very small.
The smallest it can be is 2 Z0.
So n must be greater than
or equal to 2 Z0 over pi.
This is because e, since
e is greater than 0.
So the left hand
side is a number
that is greater than 2 Z0,
and the right-hand side
must therefore be that way.
All right, so this
is a possibility.
But then, let's calculate
those values of the energies.
Calculate those en's.
So what do we have?
We squared the left
hand side for Z0
squared times and 1 plus en is
equal to pi squared n squared.
And en is equal to minus
1 plus n squared pi
squared over 4 Z0 squared.
OK, this is quantitatively nice.
But probably still doesn't
give us much intuition about
what's going on.
So let me go back
to the total energy.
en, remember, was
energy divided by V0.
So multiply all terms by V0.
E equals minus V0 plus n
squared pi squared V0 over 4.
Z0 squared, I'm going
to go all the way back
to conventional language.
And, too, 4 times Z0
squared, which is 2ma
squared V0 over h bar squared.
So E is minus V0 plus
n squared pi squared.
The V0s cancel.
h squared over 2n
times 2a squared.
I think I got every term right.
So what does this say?
Well, think of the potential.
In this region,
there's an e here.
And there's minus V0 there.
So it says E is minus
V0 plus this quantity.
So minus V0 plus this
quantity, which is n
squared pi squared h squared
over 2m times 2a squared.
So the resonance
happens if the energy
is a distance above the
bottom of the potential, which
is equal to this quantity.
And now, you see
something that we could
have seen maybe some other way.
That what's happening here is a
little strange at first sight.
These are the energy levels
of an infinite square
well of width, 2a.
If you remember, the energy
levels of an infinite square
well are n squared
pi squared h squared
over 2m times the width squared.
And those are exactly it.
So the energies at which
you find the transmission,
and the name is going to
become obvious in a second,
it's called the
resonant transition,
are those in which
the energy coincides
with some hypothetical
energy of the infinite square
well that you would put here.
If it is as if you would have
put an infinite square well
in the middle and
look at where are
the energies of bound states
that are bigger than 0,
that might be bouncing
the energies here,
but those are not
relevant, because you only
consider energies positive.
So if you find an
energy that is positive,
that corresponds to a would-be
of infinite square well, that's
it.
That's an energy for which
you will have transmission.
And in fact, if we
think about this
from the viewpoint
of the wave function,
this factor over here, look
at this property over here.
So what do we have?
The condition was
that k2 time 2a,
the argument of
the sine function
would be a multiple of pi.
But k2 is 2 pi over the
wavelength of the wave
that you have in
this range, over 2a.
It's equal to n pi.
So we can cancel
the pis and the 2s
so that you get 2a over
lambda is equal to n over 2.
And what does that say?
It says that the de
Broglie wavelength
that you have in this region
is such that it fits into 2a.
Let me write it
yet in another way.
Let me try this a as--
I won't write it like that.
Leave it like that.
The wavelength lambda fits
into 2a a half-integer number
of times.
And that's exactly what you
have in an infinite square well.
If you have a width, well, you
could have half a wavelength
there for n equals 1, a
full thing for n equals 2,
3 halves for n equals 3.
You always get half and
halves and halves increasing
and increasing all the time.
Yeah.
So the way I think
I wanted to do it,
this equation can
be written as n is
equal to 2a over lambda over 2.
That's the same equation.
So in this way, you see an
integer a number of times
is 2a divided by lambda
over 2, which is precisely
the condition for infinite
square well energy eigenstate.
So there is no infinite square
well anywhere in this problem.
But somehow, when the
wavelength of the de Broglie
representation of the
particle in this region
is an exact number of
half-waves, there's resonance.
And this resonance is
such that it allows a wave
to go completely through.
It's a pretty
remarkable phenomenon.
So the infinite
square well appears
just as a way to think of what
are the energies at which you
will observe the resonances.
But the resonance is simply
due to having an exact number
of half-waves in this region.
So we can do on a
little numerical example
to show how that works.